comedy ist einfach so ein änderte das
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem neuen video
normalerweise sage ich mal bei anderen
wie wir ob ich versuche mir das jetzt
auch zu gewöhnen besser ist es nicht
deutschland das ist ein weniger deutsche
auf jeden fall habe ich heute einen
special guest ist denn wir haben
zusammen drei kreisklassen mitgemacht
und wir haben uns gedacht wir machen mal
ein cooles video zu sagen ihr könnt ja
wahrscheinlich auch schon sehen was wir
hier eingekauft haben eine friteuse von
38 euro irgendwie waren galt auch hier
im supermarkt und haben einige trude
lebensmittel gekauft wir wollen
insgesamt zwei videos machen 1991 bei
mir verlängern wir euch natürlich in der
video beschreibung und auch am ende und
jetzt müssen wir schauen ach so ich habe
noch gar nicht gesagt worum es geht also
man kann erahnen so aber du kannst ja
mal sagen wir ums geld ging also ich
habe mal ein video gesehen wo halt leute
irgendwie alles fertig haben was ihnen
so eingefallen ist deshalb habe ich alex
geschrieben und wir haben uns eine
friteuse gekauft genau
also man muss sagen wir sind nicht die
ersten muss ist inspiriert vorher keine
ahnung soll schon so viele deswegen ja
das ding hat eine art dass keiner von
uns lernen hat vom frittieren also ich
hatte auch nie mein leben überhaupt
nicht für sie zu hause auch als kind
nicht ich auch nicht wieso sonst als
kind so was ja wenn die eltern somit
sektion auch erstmal ein bisschen muss
frittieren hermann der oma hatte schon
die krise mit sechs händler
wenn du zu hause bei den eltern wohnen
meine eltern machen essen und fernsehen
oder das macht jetzt mehr sind
er hat jeden fall hatte ich so was auch
nicht mehr hast du so dass wir irgend
genau ich bin und so hat zu meinem
dritten lebensjahr habe ich zum
geburtstag freute sich ok dann müssen
zum anfangen oder ich habe es nämlich
die kugel aber wir brauchen noch eine
gabel damit geht es so die eier
verkleinern können also eigentlich war
in dem tutorial das ich mir angeschaut
habe braucht man eigentlich mail und
semmelbrösel und wir dachten uns in
paniermehl ist 21 vielleicht wenn
willkommen
willst du vielleicht mal deine das
zeigen die bücher ausgeliefert an diesem
einfachen obwohl ich bis jetzt noch
nicht verstanden haben genau das machen
was wir deswegen haben wir dieses dings
personifizierte banane in asia ich für
mich dieses liebe wir versuchen sein wir
haben zum beispiel auch noch ein
croissant
sneakers pickup mozzarella croissant
wir haben viel zu wenig ich habe doch
gesagt ich mache das vielleicht ich will
das nicht
naja ich frag mich ganz schön mit dem
ganzen zeug hier machen sollen deswegen
bin ich ein bisschen ja zu wenig ich
habe nochmals sollte jetzt aber ich auch
maximal jetzt warten wir mal
und jetzt können wir schon mal mit
diesem kann machen wir die pizza auf mit
dem per e mail oder einfach so rein wie
können wir einfach so macht schon okay
und jetzt kommt das hier drauf honig
starb mein studium so weit dass man ja
dann kannst du schon mal was sagen wir
dann ein bisschen weiß wahrscheinlich
stellt momentan immer auf das
polizeirevier die ganze übernahme so sie
könnte auch jetzt noch ne wurst aber
deswegen muss es ja herr schneider ist
das ganze warte jetzt kommt mir das
darüber abtropfen lassen und dann ja
jetzt steht alles entdecken ja und dann
gleich in die friteuse damit das video
geht auf jeden fall ewig du kannst du
mir jetzt die zwiebeln schneiden
2000 jahre später so wir hoffen mal dass
das jetzt fertig ist
weil ich habe eigentlich gedacht das ist
blöd halten wir jetzt den chor ein paar
tricks hast du schon mal frittiert muss
das bloggern hsg tja so banal es klingt
doch schön sich das ist ja auch hier
wurden direkt mit dem kopf war eine
augen
okay leute übrigens so wie sieht jetzt
diese banane aus eigentlich echt schöne
wie auf der kirmes oder so
oder wie eine misslungene ist
fischstäbchen oder ein bisschen ja dann
schnitzel also dass jemand irgendwo eine
banane frittiert haben habe ich auch
noch nie gesehen echt aber es gibt doch
beim asia dingen das zusammenführen
[Musik]
irgendwie manchmal spät weil ich finde
das ekelhafteste frittierte böse aber
danke
das merkt wie fisch also das lied wie
fisch also chips sind gar nicht
irgendwie ich denke dass hier oder und
rein damit
guten appetit leute so sehen jetzt die
nachschuss aus jetzt ist doch irgendwie
gut aber irgendwas stimmt sich auf jeden
fall 1000 noch mit bananen kennen sie
das wenn du dir nicht sicher bist mache
habe ich den geschmack von was zu
irgendwie finde es geil aber irgendwie
auch voll abstoßen hören schmecken
also ich bin überzeugt denn es war auch
noch gut dann machen wir jetzt weiter
mit diesem coup ballaballa picco bella
bello malerei nehmen wir ein paar mehr
von mir dass sie so zusammen kleben oder
alex kann nicht passieren
er weiß nicht wie das geht du wusstest
du dass du selber muss man hier auch die
gabe alles sieht aus wie ein magnet
heute schaut euch das mal eine banane
und eine zwiebel das kann man ja nur in
einem essen
aber ich war in der zwischenzeit schon
mal hier diese dinger rein weißt du was
glaube ich schlauer ist natürlich dass
die fraktionen die hand nehmen oder und
dann schon weil daraus machen und wir
dann den ball durchschneiden
gemeint war
jetzt wo zukunft ja und rein machst du
das hier ist eine zwiebel drin
ich weiß dass ich später noch zu dem
event geben jetzt einfach noch zwiebel
steht er ja das sieht doch gut aus
die common dieser walter und da sind
jetzt einfach mal denkt und schicken das
verkaufen sie beim heute schaut euch mal
das da an das ist einfach gummibärchen
paniert probier mal
[Musik]
hmm gut oder kann man das natürlich
probieren
ich gebe dir zehn euro wenn du den
ganzen ball ist jedes mal zu viel haben
wir jetzt einfach so rein
[Musik]
so riecht es wird also schon fertig ok
dann lasst uns herausholen hätte sie
schon geil aus doch jetzt spricht es
nicht so verliert haben ist das
interessant also die erste pizza ist
raus ohne panade sieht so aus eigentlich
ganz gut war
noch aber hat sich mal der ganze käse
ist ja unten aber der in die salami auch
weg
[Musik]
so wird es dafür schneller brauchst du
den text an open
willst du die salami haben ich mag das
nicht
ich bin noch die gabe mit hey du hast
die du hast gesagt haben ich möchte
kann man erst mal aber mit ungemein da
ist sich schmitt zählt halt mal durch
das sieht hier so eklig aus klassischen
dazwischen und auch noch ein paar
komiker und jetzt noch alles in mixa
bisschen wasser dazu dann trinken
geil das wird aber richtig geil weißt du
was du mit dem größer machen
wir tun das nix rein in das geschäft und
dann richtig geisteskrank daran haben
wir noch weiter nach oben drückt aber
nimmst du viel zu heiß das geht schon
so heißt es nicht okay warte 32 okay wir
haben jetzt fünf sachen probieren was
kannst du von allen am besten
ich fande die pizza also die planierte
bitte auf jeden fall
und diese ballaballa die nachschuss kann
ich gut zwiebel wand war auch in ordnung
bei einer hast alles gut aber lange
warten bis apple haft was sie gar nicht
doch doch na ja gut wir werden jetzt
noch weitere sachen kann ihren wie zum
beispiel kartons sneakers und pick ups
und am brenner also das video dazu ist
in der videos verlinkt schaut es auf
jeden fall an abonniert sehr gerne auf
ihrem kanal
kanal und wir sehen unsere morgen schon
wieder gibt es neues video bereit